hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal
wieder aus türkisches so viel akribie
wann macht man wieder was türkisches
heute ist es soweit aber vorab ich muss
sagen ich weiß nicht ob es in anderen
ländern auch gibt mit sicherheit ich
persönlich kenne sätzen aus der
türkischen küche
wir machen den ich zucchini koffer mit
wären heißt optisch oder missfällt dass
man so schwierig auszusprechen auf jeden
fall gibt es ja du weißt bessern die
araber wo ich sage ich jetzt auch
erstmal die zutaten wir benötigen
natürlich zucchini außerdem eier und
mehl salz und pfeffer habe ich hier
getrocknete minze edel süßes
paprikapulver und petersilie und noch
etwas öl zum ausbacken
der teig ist eigentlich super schnell
hergestellt das einzige was jetzt
vorbereiten müssen die zucchini habe ich
erst mal das vordere stück abgemacht und
che sie jetzt und als nächstes reifen
will sie fein das habe ich jetzt mit der
ersten zucchini schon mal machen die
zweite kommt jetzt hinterher
und das wäre erledigt und reize die von
natur aus sehr viel wasser enthält wir
sind einfach nicht gebrauchen können
während der es nicht ausdrücken das geht
ganz gut mit den händen die könnte aber
auch ein buch nehmen ich habe euch mal
wie ich das mache ich nehme immer so
eine handvoll dann bringe ich das hier
aus und schauen mal wie viel wasser da
rauskommt so der teil wäre erledigt und
die reste die eigentlich gar keine reste
sind die könnte jetzt weiterverarbeiten
zu gemüsesuppe zum beispiel also nicht
wegschmeißen
ich geb's ja ganz kurz anbieter und für
den teig gehen wir jetzt alle restlichen
zutaten in die schüssel bis auf das öl
[Musik]
ich habe den teig jetzt mit den sauberen
händen verknetet hat jetzt auch keinen
handschuh genommen hat schon nämlich
persönlich mal gerne wenn ich wohnten an
den fingern habe oder wenn das fleisch
ist oder so ein richtig klebriger teig
aber das habe ich jetzt so erledigt und
ich hole jetzt ganz kurz meine fahne und
dann backen die aus ihr habt nichts
verpasst keine sorge ich habe die ersten
schon mal hoch erst nur schon mal
ausgebacken so und gemeinsam backen wir
zu wissen ich hab natürlich ist stefanie
nimmt nicht die allerhöchste stufe aber
geht schon ein bisschen höher und ist
nämlich mit zwei esslöffel zu hilfe und
macht dann immer so runde kleine tal
heraus
[Musik]
meine zucchini puffer sind fertig und
sie brauchen in der pfanne ungefähr
eineinhalb minuten pro seite und weil
ich wusste dass die frage aufkommen wie
habe ich einem ofen ausprobiert bei 200
grad zehn minuten also es funktioniert
auch es ist aber bei weitem nicht so
knusprig als wenn man sie austreten so
dass nur so am rande ich empfehle auf
jeden fall die pfannen variante mit öl
und ich mache jetzt noch einen tipp dazu
das zeige ich euch ich habe hier einfach
nur joghurt 1,5 prozent
natürlich auch 35 14 prozent hinnehmen
ganz euch überlassen und ich bin das
jetzt noch auf mit salz und knoblauch
und am ende kommt dann noch ein bisschen
getrocknete minze drüber so falls ihr
jetzt auch richtig lust habt auch die
türkischen zucchini puffer dann schaut
unten in den boxster schreibe ich euch
wie immer die genauen mengenangaben hin
ansonsten gibt's dem video vielleicht
nicht ein dörfchen nach oben kommentiert
was jetzt nicht aussehen möchte gerne
auch wieder die türkische richtung da
war nimmt die nachfrage immer ganz hoch
kann es nur türkische gerichte zeigen
mache ich immer von herzen gerne also
eure vorschläge gerne in die kommentare
ansonsten abonniert main kanal kostenlos
wenn es nicht schon längst getan habt
und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten mal auch die gis kitchen
tschüss
[Musik]